well I it's it's like a weird complex
like
[Music]
women were always like go out of their
way to tell you when they have a toxic
ex and oh like I've had so many girls on
my show say oh I had this a toxic
abusive this this X and it's just to the
point where I sometimes question The
credibility because I've just had so
many people do it and men don't don't
come forward like that if anything like
I've had guys pull me aside after the
show and tell me a story but they don't
come on usually I do agree with that I
do agree with what you're saying but I
do feel like is it feel as though
men because sex is so accessible they
don't have to treat you that well
because they know they've conquered you
they know that they're bonded to you
like like if when a woman has sex with a
guy she's bonded to the guy so well then
girls wouldn't leave girls leave 70 to
80 of the time well yeah I guess that's
true but sometimes they're leaving for
someone else well sometimes you know
it's another guy that they're pursuing
for whatever reason an ex-boyfriend so
sometimes it's not but my thing is like
I just don't think we should believe
women without evidence and if you
haven't pressed charges like I'm sorry I
don't know you like you need to press
charges and like if somebody's punching
me in the face I would press charges I
don't understand why you wouldn't it's
easier said than done yeah it's it's not
necessarily for women for women for
women it's pretty easy the Law's on your
side for men it's not it's harder for
men but sometimes it can be hard like
you can't I feel like those are subjects
you can't really speak on because
mentally you you're what if that guy
mentally breaks you down to a point
where he says that boom if you go to the
police I'll know like you just can't
speak on certain things like that like
it's easier said than done like it takes
it will take up a lot for women to pick
up that courage to leave somebody that's
mentally abuse them and physically abuse
them and control them to a certain
extent where they're even afraid to but
I think my thing is women will go on
public platforms and destroy a man's
reputation they know yeah I feel like
that so I'm saying like if if you're not
willing to go to the police and you come
on a public platform where people know
you they know who you dated it's not
fair that we just believe them if they
didn't if there's no evidence it should
be innocent improved yeah everything
yeah and so it's like I I think you
should press charges if that happened
okay and if not you're going to go on a
public platform and destroy a man's
reputation without any like evidence I
can't just believe you if I don't know
you I guess it's a society we live in
now like Council culture they feel like
sometimes it's easier to go online and
do that you get better result by doing
that because I had to look at it at one
time like why wouldn't you rather just
go to the police rather than you coming
online doing it but I guess now it's
like Council college is easier but the
ones that are coming with fake stories
and I'm just out well I don't I don't
know what's fake and what's real but it
it seems disingenuous to me if you're
coming if you're too scared to go to
police but you're brave enough to come
and tell talk about it on my back okay
yeah so yeah
like that's I'm not saying like some
women aren't scared to go to police I
know that happens but it's just like
it's it's odd to me yeah yeah sorry I
misunderstood no no it's you're okay
you're okay I I know that um
that you know a be like but the other
thing that's crazy about abuse is
actually the majority of the time um
they're hitting each other and that's a
lot of times girls like they forget to
talk about this or the majority of
abusive relationships are both hitting
each other so they'll say oh I was
abused and I'll be like okay did you hit
him yes so you were abusing each other
but what you saw Advantage yes because
yeah lose loser for us in this country
so if I say he was beating me up two
minutes ago people are gonna believe
that mm-hmm
that they're going to believe it because
I'm a woman and also that's the
disadvantage I'm a female so that's not
a good thing but unfortunately a lot of
women do use it to their advantage
though yeah and you can hit first and
then he hits women always do yeah and
and then he hits you back and now you're
the victim it's like um the if it's
one-sided abuse 70 of the time it's a
woman hitting a man and not vice versa
and so knowing these stats and when I
come on these platforms like I'm like
why
why don't I have men coming forward as
much as women and the only the only
times I do it's usually like in DMS or
like messages
yeah it's like that guy that reached out
to you he I think he would
that's the first step man like be open
you you you will grow if you're if
you're willing to do it yeah what did
you say back to him
did you reply
I get a lot of tea okay
I get I get so many sometimes it's like
overwhelming I read a lot have you ever
had one where you did reply and you
remember or no yeah I've replied to a
couple
um there is one guy who told me like
basically that it was really sad like
this was one of the saddest DMS I've
ever gotten like basically he's never he
was like addicted to hookers and he's
never had a girl like interested in
having sex with him ever and he's like I
got in shape I did this I did this and
like no but not anymore now then now
like it was like two years later he's
addicted to Corn hooker like you know
like bad bad stuff and I was just like
damn that would never happen to a woman
not not in the same way you know because
like women always have someone that
wants to sleep with them always for the
most part and so it's like I feel like
there's a level of loneliness that women
just don't understand or like we will
never understand because like I don't
think that would ever happen to me or
any woman I know
it was really sad it is sad but it
I do believe there's a way out for a lot
of guys I I do that's that's why I
responded I was like okay you should try
this this and then I was like I'm
Despair and I'm like okay I don't know
how else yeah
like I don't know how else to help you
I'm like trying to give you some thank
you
thank you the the solution to Modern
dating yeah
I think the laws have to change that's
what I think I think if we want to
incentivize men to get married again the
laws have to change
um personally I feel like all the
problems would go with we got rid of
birth control but I don't see that
happening I think that's like the root
of everything
yeah I think that's part of it but go
ahead
oh gosh what do you think
I'm so happy my face is covered I think
women they either need to lower their
expectations or get out of the workforce
okay that's a good one because if they
lower their expectations and their the
income of a man is not
um it doesn't need to be higher then I
think that's great but I think once they
leave the workforce they'll have a lot
more options
um
what's that word that they use like when
the man makes more hypogamy yeah yeah
they'll be more hypergamous that way
I think they still have to be able to
submit to a guy that makes less yeah
there are powerful CEOs that still come
home and submit to their husbands yes
yes like you think you think that
Supreme Court Justice in the U.S I
forget her name
um but she's like super accomplished I
guarantee she comes home she has like a
four or five kids yeah she's really
pretty yeah yeah you know what I'm
talking about she I bet you like ABC or
something or ACB I can't remember her
name off the top of my head she's pretty
yeah yeah yeah she I'm like she she
comes home home and submits even though
she's more accomplished than her husband
but it's interesting because on this
show like I'll ask girls like how much
would a guy I have to make for you to
quit your job for him and it's always
like top 10 percent yeah but it's kind
of like in the 1950s like the guy made
if a guy made like like a like a living
like the equivalent of like minimum wage
it was still more than what she was
making so it would be normal for her to
to want to submit to that because she's
not bringing anything in but it's like
we've come to a point where like no
one's no one's talking about like how
like we can't keep going like this like
like women say they want a guy that
makes more than why are you like saying
that women need to chase the bag like
yeah it doesn't make any sense like
numbers wise right right what do you
think
um is the solution to Modern dating
um
I would say submission number one
understanding submission
and communication I feel like women can
still work and submit to their husband
and still add more and be able to submit
because God forbid you're married and
your husband is sick and he's the
breadwinner and even if for example
you're not out working but he's making
money and you have your own little side
hustle or something just as long as
you're getting some sort of income
that's very important because as I said
before the woman is a helper how are you
going to help your husband in that time
you're eventually gonna have to go out
and work and in that moment
it's a moment where women can get big
headed like okay cool I'm the head of
the house now I'm making all the money
I'm supporting you but once you submit
and understand that you're here to help
and it's only for a short period of time
then yeah I think that submission
understanding each other's roles in a
relationship communication also
lowering your standards a little bit
sometimes not expect like why would you
ask a guy to have this this and that and
you barely have nothing to amount to
that like come on be realistic like
Diane you make 25 000 a year you want to
make six figures you get me like it does
not make sense Diane
it does not make sense but yeah that's
what I think okay go ahead yeah I think
to to just piggyback off of that I think
flipping the whole idea of settling
right because if you ultimately want to
be with a man right if you're uh
Sleeping with a bunch of guys who are
you know the top 10 you know the top of
the top but none of them want to commit
to you I see that as settling because
all you're settling for is sleeping
around if you want a long-term
commitment
and I will also speak from a guy's
perspective because we are playing the
game we're playing
you gotta play it man you gotta level up
so like that's what I've done in my life
and try to continue to do
I know it does work it does work and I
do think like I just said like just
being realistic you know if and the last
thing is to tie in with being realistic
I think we should communicate more about
body clock because I don't think a lot
of people know this
about you know losing I think it's
losing 90 of your ninety percent of your
eggs are gone by 30 by 30. like
as so many geriatric pregnancy starts at
35 and if you want to do that you have
to have twenty thousand dollars of cash
like ready to go and it might not even
work like what if you had that on it I
know this sounds crazy but imagine it
was on a dating app like you set up a
profile and it goes what do you want I
want marriage okay how old are you cool
this is your probable biological clock
maybe you should go get your eggs
checked because that's actually what you
want you don't want to date around and
sleep with a bunch of guys because
that's actually you've just answered the
form do you know what I'm saying yeah
like because a lot of times I think
like women will be like I'll have girls
in my show they'll be like 30 31 32 and
it's like if you want to have kids you
like how long are you going to date the
guy before you have kids and it's like
you might want to get in like there's
still oh I'm having fun like I don't
know what you know and it's like okay
you know time's ticking
um yeah it's true because I've got a
friend who's out there in the streets
dating in their 40s and she's enjoying
the dating experience
but as I said to her you kind of past
that really you've got to know what you
want how to get it yeah and I think
women really sometimes don't know we're
full of contradictions we say we might
want a dating experience but at the same
time we're thinking about a lifetime
partner but how do you get that through
just doing that yeah I mean being
serious about it yeah and I think we
mean sometimes we can fluctuate
sometimes we want a man sometimes we
don't sometimes we just
because we're not getting what we want
we we then
add other things onto the list of things
that I'm not getting and the reason why
I'm not getting that would you ladies in
the room if you knew that stat ahead of
time would that have changed your dating
choices so I'm assuming you didn't know
that stat maybe you did but I didn't
know that stat I knew that they you lost
your eggs over time but I didn't know it
was as bad as that so do you think it
would have maybe changed your dating
choices if you knew that
I could be wrong
as many of you know I was just bad
Tick Tock and we are demonetized
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible